-As President Trump's ex-lawyer
was headed to jail,
Trump got definitive,
ironclad proof
that he did not collude
with Russia
from the president of Russia.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-After Special Counsel
Robert Mueller spent two years
putting together
a 400-page report
documenting President Trump's
various links
to Russian President
Vladimir Putin,
Trump decided that Friday,
as he was in the middle
of staging an unprecedented
stand-off with Congress
over his administration's
handling of that report,
was the perfect time
to brag about
his close relationship
with Vladimir Putin.
-I had a very good talk
with President Putin,
probably over an hour.
And we talked about many things.
-Mr. President, did you address
the election meddling issues
that came up in the Mueller
Report with Mr. Putin today?
-We discussed that.
He actually sort of smiled
when he said
something to the effect
that it started off
as a mountain
and it ended up being a mouse.
But he knew that,
because he knew
there was no collusion
whatsoever.
-And I'm sorry.
Can we go back to this?
-We discussed that.
He actually sort of smiled...
-How did you know
he was smiling? Did you --
[ Laughter ]
Did you try to call him
and accidentally hit
the FaceTime button, Grandpa?
[ Laughter ]
Putin doesn't seem like the
kind of guy who would FaceTime
unless he's beaming into
the U.N. on a giant screen
demanding a billion dollars
or he'll kill James Bond.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I would definitely
believe --
I would definitely believe Putin
was smiling when they talked.
99% of the time
he looks like this.
Though when he sees Trump,
he lights up like he just heard
there was a sale on poison.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now given that Trump and his
Attorney General William Barr
have repeatedly lied about
the Mueller Report,
Democrats in the House have
asked for Mueller himself
to come testify.
And on Sunday,
one Democrat said
they'd reached a tentative date
of May 15th
for Mueller to testify.
So naturally Trump freaked out
on Twitter.
-"After spending
more than $35 million
over a two-year period
interviewing 500 people,
using 18 Trump-hating angry
Democrats and 49 FBI agents,
all culminating in a more than
400-page report
showing no collusion, why would
the Democrats in Congress
now need Robert Mueller
to testify?
Are they looking for a redo
because they hated seeing
the strong "no collusion"
conclusion?
There was no crime except
on the other side,
incredibly not covered
in the report,
and no obstruction.
Bob Mueller should not
testify.
No redos for the Dems."
-Okay, first of all,
"no redos"?
How is it that Trump always
seems to be 100 years old
and seven years old
at the same time?
[ Laughter ]
Watches Fox News, 100.
Thinks trucks are rad, seven.
[ Laughter ]
Thinks Robert E. Lee
is rad, 100.
Likes McDonald's, seven.
[ Laughter ]
Second, I thought you said --
[ Applause ]
I thought you said Mueller
exonerated you?
Why don't you want him
to testify?
"I'm afraid he'll make me look
too innocent.
I have to maintain some of
my criminal mystique."
[ Laughter ]
It really doesn't help your case
when you tell the cops
you have an alibi,
but they can't talk to anyone
who can verify it.
"Oh, Brad can tell you. I was
bowling during the robbery.
But whatever you do,
don't talk to Brad!"
[ Laughter ]
But we need to hear
from Mueller himself
because Trump and his Attorney
General have spent weeks lying
about what Mueller wrote
in his report.
You might remember the report
concluded basically
what any rational person
who has spent the last two years
paying attention to the news
expected it might say.
That even though there was
no criminal conspiracy
between the Trump campaign
and Russia,
there were numerous links
between the Russian government
and the Trump campaign,
and the campaign expected
it would benefit electorally
from information stolen
and released
through Russian efforts.
So the Trump campaign was
specifically informed
over and over again that Russia
was trying to help them
win the election by offering
dirt on Hillary Clinton.
And over and over again,
the Trump campaign invited
and welcomed that help.
Most people, if you offered them
a free TV and said,
"I stole this from Best Buy,"
they'd say, "I don't want that
and I'm calling the cops,"
but if you offered it to Trump,
he'd mount it on his wall with
a plaque under it that said,
"Free TV stolen from Best Buy."
[ Laughter ]
You might also remember
that when Barr issued
his infamous four-page
summary of Mueller's report
in March, he left out
all that information
and all the evidence
Mueller had gathered
on obstruction of justice.
So Mueller,
who never speaks publicly,
took the extraordinary step
of writing to Barr
to complain to him that Barr's
letter exonerating Trump
"did not fully capture
the context, nature,
and substance of this office's
working conclusions."
Context, nature, and substance.
So basically, everything.
Barr even got the author's
name wrong.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Mueller's report
listed 10 separate times
Trump may have
obstructed justice
during the investigation.
Now, one of those 10 instances
involves Trump's
former White House Counsel
Don McGahn.
McGahn told Mueller that Trump
had ordered him twice
to fire Mueller.
He was so concerned about it,
he then told
Chief of Staff Reince Priebus
and even used some
colorful language.
-According the report,
President Trump ordered
former White House Counsel
Don McGahn
to have Mueller fired.
The President called McGahn
at home and directed him
to call the acting Attorney
General, Rod Rosenstein,
and say that the Special Counsel
had conflicts of interest
and must be removed.
-It's also the colorful
reporting from this report
where Don McGahn says
to Reince Priebus,
which is the third witness
to this incident,
"The President asked me
to do some crazy [bleep]."
-It doesn't surprise me
that Trump would tell his aides
to do crazy [bleep] to interfere
in an investigation.
He probably tells
them to do crazy [bleep]
just to pass the time.
[ Laughter ]
"Rudy, do that thing
where you pull the skin
all the way back behind
your head.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Thank you, Rudy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You've cheered me up."
[ Cheering ]
So Democrats want McGahn
to testify in public.
Now, he's already testified
to Mueller.
And Trump and Barr
have both claimed
that the report
exonerates Trump.
So you'd think
they'd have no problem
with McGahn speaking publicly.
And yet on Friday,
Trump said he might invoke
executive privilege
to stop McGahn
from testifying to Congress.
-Mr. President, did you decide
whether you will invoke
executive privilege as it
relates to Don McGahn?
-That'll all be determined
over the next week or so.
-But you said it was done.
-But, you know,
I will say this,
there's been no President
in history
that has given
what I've given
in terms of looking at just
a total witch hunt.
I let him interview the lawyer,
the White House lawyer
for 30 hours.
Think of that, 30 hours.
-Yeah, but do you understand
how bad that sounds for you?
If your friend went to therapy,
and you said, "How was it?"
and they said, "I was there
for 30 hours," you'd be like,
"Damn, you must be dealing
with some crazy [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
Now, all of this
was happening --
[ Cheers and applause ]
All of this was happening
as Trump's former lawyer
and personal fixer,
Michael Cohen,
was preparing to report to jail
in part for a crime
involving the President.
And in a press conference before
he reported to prison today,
Cohen hinted that there was
even more to come.
-I hope that when I rejoin
my family and friends,
that the country will be
in a place without xenophobia,
injustice, and lies
at the helm of our country.
There still remains
much to be told.
And I look forward to the day
that I can share the truth.
-Wait, there's more?
[ Laughter ]
Well, tell us.
You can't just hint
at something like that
and then peace out
for three years.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if you're about
to go under for surgery
and your doctor leans over
and says,
"Okay, we're just going to take
out your appendix
and then maybe, uh,
some other stuff.
[ Laughter ]
You'll just find out what
when you wake up."
[ Laughter ]
Cohen keeps dropping hints like
this at his hearing in February
where he named Trump
as the individual who directed
the illegal hush money scheme
to cover up the affair
with Stormy Daniels.
Cohen hinted that the President
had broken even more laws
that we're not aware of.
-Is there any other wrongdoing
or illegal act
that you are aware of
regarding Donald Trump
that we haven't yet
discussed today?
-Yes.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
How do you leave something like
that just hanging out there?
It's like if you're at a party
playing "Never Have I Ever"
and someone goes,
"Never have I ever...
fallen into a toilet and gotten
stuck there for 30 days,
surviving only on toilet water
until a friend found me
and called 9-1-1
and they had to lift me out
of the building on a crane
while I was still stuck
in the toilet
and take me to the hospital,
where the toilet was surgically
removed from my butt."
And then one guy just quietly
takes a sip of his beer
and goes, "Okay, who's next?"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, can someone --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can someone maybe
go find Cohen
and, you know, ask him
a follow-up question?
We all know where he is.
Before he went to prison,
he was spotted in Manhattan
all the time.
And on Saturday, cameras
were literally following him
down the street paparazzi-style.
I mean, look at this.
This guy has more paparazzi
following him than I do.
One time,
a single photographer
followed me for 45 minutes.
When I asked him to stop,
he said, "Oh, sorry,
I thought you were the guy
from 'The Office.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So Trump's ex-fixer
reported to jail today.
And on top of that, we have
more than 400 pages of evidence
in which it's clear
that the President's campaign
benefited from
a criminal conspiracy
to steal information
during the 2016 election,
and then repeatedly
lied about it
and tried to stop
the investigation of it.
We need Mueller and McGahn
to testify,
and we need Congress
to do its job.
Otherwise, Trump will have
at least two more years
to indulge in his
favorite activity --
-Crazy [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]